tom why don't you give everybody an
update on the message you got from
american airlines and gas
fuel shortage what's that all about yeah
so i think everybody that has a frequent
flyer number um
whether you're on delta american
airlines i know delta american airlines
apparently sent out this week
santa notices saying hey there's some
fuel shortages please bear with us we
may
cancel a few flights here and there uh
instead of four flights a day maybe
three
and expect a uh the year end at the end
of summer
and uh back to school things tightening
up in terms of prices going up and
please bear with us
i've that is not a customer service
message
it seemed like a warning that the
airlines are preparing for a rough fall
that's what it sounded like airlines are
looking for a rough
fall fuel shortages yesterday i'm
talking to a guy that runs a
uh uh fair prices they said he he runs a
uh
what do you call it he builds home so
what do you call when you're general
contractor
general contract yeah but you know how
you come and see the model homes and
then he builds the model home for you
with it oh he's a developer
yeah he's a developer so i said so how's
business he calls me says you know what
i'm so pissed off right now so what are
you pissed off about he says my main guy
my main gc that i've been using for the
last 10 years
every time we do a deal together the
property is up the house is up within
six months today
i'm talking to him he says he can't do
it for me for 12 months
i said so what are you doing he said i
got an option number two in an option he
says i called everybody in town right
everybody says 12 months there's nothing
i can do about it i said you have no
leverage today
i said so what's your game plan he said
i'm calling the guy the gc to tell him
typically whatever you were charging me
i'm willing to charge
i'm willing to pay 20 percent more for
you to do it
in six months because his guy is saying
there is shortage so he's calling the
clients
to say look if you want this thing to be
built up i can do it but if you want it
in six months
you got to pay that 20 so it's a very
interesting time right now
it's not just shortage of fuel there's
shortage in a lot of things today
well absolutely as a matter of fact uh
php your other business is doing
fantastic and what are you so what are
you doing you're expanding your
headquarters
and your cmo and you're doing the uh and
you're doing the remodel and you know
that i'm i see that in dallas right in
the middle of it
and the the contractor said the same
thing and it's it's situational
concrete and drywall apparently are near
impossible to get
in uh in dallas concrete and drywall not
near impossible erase the audio a little
bit still a little low for me folks is
your is my audio low just tell me if it
is or not i'm curious but go ahead
yeah and that what he's saying is
situational and he was saying the things
that need
shipping like there are some lights and
some other things for the ceiling we're
not ordering custom lights
you know but uh he says look i can't get
things in i'm trying to get things
shipped he said there's a trucker
shortage which was the
similar thing that i saw last night uh
network news talking about that the
trucking shortages transporting fuel
because it's fuel member takes up a lot
of space it's heavy you have a lot of
rail a lot of tank
he said they can't get it so he said
shipping concrete drywall
in dallas and it's affecting the
completion date remember this is
supposed to be done mid-summer now it's
not going to be done
yeah yeah the new so we'll see what's
going to happen well somebody that's
been in construction for people out
there that don't know the way that it
affects prices is normally the the
the valuation that we all give is two
parts parts one part labor
so somebody's gonna be more expensive on
labor because there's not enough of it
that they're gonna do something
12 months out and parts are already more
expensive
so you're you're doubling down on the
labor cost actually in that
in that regard because we don't in in
construction we don't charge
by time i'm not a 20 an hour employee or
whatever right
it's if the parts of this are ten
thousand dollars
then i charge five thousand dollars it's
a fifteen thousand dollar project that's
how you come up with your valuations two
parts parts one part labor
so if the parts are already more
expensive the labor's already charging
more
so if the parts cost me 12 grand i'm not
still charging five i'm charging six now
so that fifteen thousand dollar project
is an eighteen thousand dollar project
and now if you're kicking another twenty
percent on top of that
that fifteen thousand dollar project
just became what
seventeen five eighteen thousand just
off the bat right there
so that's three thousand dollars right
now off of the same exact project
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you wanna see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye